hey you guys welcome back to flickers of
fear the movie that we're talking about
today is uh kind of like a random pic
this is so so weird all right so we're
talking about this movie which i kind of
feel like is a really really forgotten
thriller from 1987 and it's called dead
of winter
now when i was doing a search on youtube
for other reviews of this just to kind
of get an idea of how other people felt
about it i found one count them
one other review of this movie and it
was like three minutes long had 66 views
and the girl really didn't like it
so i mean i kind of feel like that might
be unprecedented it's like these movies
that i didn't realize that this movie
was that obscure but uh you know you
learned something new every day i guess
but yeah so one other review i don't
think i've ever had that happen
now the reason that i picked this one
is because this is one of those ones
that i feel like was on cable a [ __ ] ton
like in the late 80s and early 90s so i
feel like this was one that
i watched a whole bunch of times but
then i didn't see it again subsequently
but obviously you know the the cover of
it the you know the name of it made
enough of an impression that when i was
scrolling through amazon prime a couple
of weeks ago i noticed that it was
free like for with this with the
subscription and i was kind of like oh i
should put that on the list and like
actually go and watch that unfortunately
by the time i got around to watching it
uh they didn't have the free one anymore
so i actually just had to pay 3.99 to
rent it which like i said is no big deal
because i'd already kind of like put it
on the schedule and plan to do it so
it's kind of one of those movies that i
was really interested
to revisit it because it's just one that
i remember seeing a lot on cable but all
i remembered from it was that mary
steenburgen was in it because i love her
actually i i think i watched everything
with her in it in the 80s just because i
liked her so much in time after time
from 1979
and also roddy mcdowell is in it and i
love him you know obviously because he's
in everything awesome but it's like
particularly
mid to late 80s like you know he was in
fright night obviously so i was just
kind of like watching everything with
him in it too so since both of them were
in it i was kind of like yeah this is
gonna be right in my wheelhouse and i
love thrillers i love all that kind of
like creepy you know it has a kind of a
little bit of a gothic uh old-fashioned
kind of vibe
so it would have been like right up my
alley i didn't really remember much
about it other than mary steinberg and
going to this creepy old house and a
dude in a wheelchair and her like
getting in some kind of trouble i didn't
remember anything about what the plot
was or you know it's just it's kind of
like your standard thriller plot but i
didn't really remember like what all the
specifics were probably because on
re-watching this i'm like this plot is
super super complicated and i'm actually
not really even sure i understand
entirely what happened but i don't know
we'll get into this so uh so this was
directed by arthur penn
who was the same guy like in the 60s and
70s he did a lot of movies he did bonnie
and clyde alice's restaurant and stuff
like that and then later on he kind of
went more into like tv and stage type
stuff i think he was like an executive
producer on law and order for a while oh
he also directed pen and tell her get
killed uh so there was that
uh this movie which i didn't know at the
time was actually kind of a remake
although
uh the movie that it was you know
supposedly loosely remaking was called
my name is julia ross and that came out
in
1945
and that movie was actually in turn
based on the 1941 novel called the woman
in red by anthony gilbert now i haven't
seen the 1945 one
but i read the synopsis
and even though in its bare bones like
kind of fiction like setup you know like
narrative setup it is similar to this
one but this one is like a lot different
um the original one is actually set in
england and it's about a woman who goes
to be like a live-in housekeeper or
something like that or living secretary
for this like sick widow
and she ends up like becoming a prisoner
there and then all the people that are
like gaslighting her into thinking she's
somebody else and like when she
uh protests this they just say oh she's
having a nervous breakdown and she
doesn't know what she's talking about so
it's like a very gas lady situation
which like i said i guess there's a lot
of that kind of stuff going on at
thrillers so like i said the bear bear
setup uh of dead of winter is similar
although some of the stuff like
motivations and stuff are different but
as far as i could determine the original
movie didn't have this really
complicated
blackmail plot which is kind of what
happens in this one so what happens in
this uh mary steenberg oh and i was
going to say too just as uh just as kind
of like evidence of how
maybe forgotten this movie is
is that this actually did come out on
blu-ray uh for a little while i think
like vhs and dvd and maybe blu-ray later
on but it's it but it didn't really have
hardly any extras on it and i think it
even then like went out of print so i
kind of feel like this is one that sort
of slipped through the cracks and
actually there were kind of like a lot
of whodunnits like good ones that came
out in the 80s looking like death trap
and sleuth and stuff like that this is
kind of along those lines you know
because i don't know it's thrillers are
just such an evergreen genre
and they make so many of them and i
guess the plots of them are sort of
similar interchangeable but i mean
that's you know that's not to say like a
lot of horror movie plots are
interchangeable too it's just like if
that's your jam if that's what you like
then that's not gonna bother you but um
i do kind of feel like if one wasn't
really really spectacular
like stand out then they made so many of
them like during this time period that a
lot of them got forgotten and this is
one of them and honestly
i kind of like
there's a lot to like about this movie
like like i said the the setup like the
mystery the plot and everything like
that when it's resolved it's kind of
like complicated and i'm not sure
that it's entirely believable
you know a lot of the stuff i'm not sure
is entirely believable and even like
reviews at the time were kind of like
yeah [ __ ] wouldn't like go down like
this or why doesn't she just do that or
why does she just do this or whatever so
i can kind of see that but i will say
that one of the best things about this
they shot it in toronto
um was this real kind of creepy i mean
it's very very like the weather is just
like this big like [ __ ] snowstorms
and blizzards so like everything's very
bleak and white and those like the dead
trees and the house that they shot it in
um is like really isolated and the
inside of it is like super super creepy
and gothic and all this other kind of
stuff like it's kind of like a hunting
lodge type situation for a long time
like i said you know that something
nefarious is going on uh with the
situation but you're not unsure entirely
what it is so it's that kind of thing so
this like i said
if you're into thrillers particularly
ones from this era like from the 80s and
you haven't seen this one that i would
recommend it's not the best one i've
ever seen uh and like i said it's a
little convoluted uh and you know there
are some there are some points in it
where probably you know
the protagonist could have like done
something else like to get herself out
of that situation and it doesn't work
out but it's a totally like passable you
know decent one and i kind of think it's
sad that it sort of got forgotten about
especially because it's kind of had a
lot of like a real big talent behind it
like i said i always really liked mary
sean bergen
and uh roddy mcdowell of course always
delightful to watch so what we have at
the very beginning you have this kind of
like
prologue sort of scene
and it's supposedly new year's eve it's
really really snowy there's this woman
whose face you don't see she's kind of
wearing like a hat and like a you know a
trench coat or whatever and she goes in
this train station and there's like this
complex that well not complex but it's
like two different lockers with this one
has a key for another one a blah blah
so she goes and gets this bag
that's full of money
and she drives her car to like the
middle of this parking lot in the middle
of nowhere
and uh you know so obviously you pretty
much know from contact's clues okay well
she's there to like drop off something
to like a blackmail or you know a ransom
or something like that
so she gets out she goes in a phone
booth and then she's like calling the
person she's like look the dude's not
here um if he doesn't come in five
minutes i'm just [ __ ] leaving because
you know
even if you're being blackmailed or
kidnapped or whatever it's just kind of
like look i got [ __ ] to do all right i'm
not waiting around uh but yeah so she
gets back in the car and then she gets
killed like a guy's in the back seat and
he strangles her and then he cuts off
her uh
ring finger like on her left hand
so that's like your prologue
then you jump ahead to uh new york city
and uh you have this woman named katie
katie mcgovern who's played by mary
steenbergen and she is working as a
waitress but she's also an actress and
like she says later on that she'd been
in some soap operas she'd been in some
commercials and stuff like that but
she's you know doing waitressing like in
between gigs as a lot of actors do
so she's live in an apartment with her i
thought initially it was her boyfriend
but i guess later he calls her his wife
so i guess that's her husband
and his name is rob i think now he's a
photographer but he has been in some
kind of accident or whatever his leg is
broken so he can't really get around all
that much so i guess like they live in
this tiny apartment and like mary
steenbergen's brother i said i keep
calling her by her afternoon katie's
brother has been staying there with them
like presumably to help take care of uh
rob like while katie's out working or
whatever so i guess they're having like
all kinds of money problems they make
like a thing about
katie's like well i really have to you
know get back to
getting some acting gigs because like
you know our old bills are behind the
rent's behind you know a bunch of [ __ ]
in the apartment is broken it's kind of
like your standard holy [ __ ] we're broke
we really need a job kind of thing
now she actually sees an ad
in
variety or whatever have you
and it sounds like kind of a good gig
now it's very vague like the wording of
it basically the ad says
we need a woman who is going to be a
leading actress to replace you know a
leading actress that left somebody needs
to travel they need we need you right
away uh you know really good pay [ __ ]
like that
so katie goes to this audition there's a
whole bunch of other women there and she
walks in
and roddy mcdowell is acting as
presumably the casting director and he
looks up at her and he's immediately
struck and he's like having her like
turn you know her head and all this
other kind of stuff hey can you put your
hair up and stuff and basically he's
like okay you know you're you're the one
uh so yeah so he doesn't even really
interview or she doesn't like uh have to
audition really or anything
so he's like basically here's the
situation we were making this movie and
we had this lead actress named julie
rose who had a nervous breakdown like
she walked off the set and had a nervous
breakdown and she doesn't want to
[ __ ] do it anymore and they want to
reuse it's like they're working on the
movie right now but they're kind of
shooting around her shooting scenes that
don't have her in it but they're
eventually going to need to shoot more
stuff with her in it but we already shot
a bunch of stuff with her so we need an
actress that looks pretty much exactly
like her so we can just kind of like you
know keep going with the movie without
trashing all the footage of her we
already shot
so he's like so we need somebody
immediately we're going up to this house
in upstate new york and you'll do like a
video screen test to make sure like with
the producers that you look enough like
the woman and that you can like learn to
do her voice and her mannerisms and
stuff and uh you know and then we'll go
from there and then you know he's gonna
love you it's gonna be cool
so and you know they offer like a
generous amount of money i think it's
like three thousand dollars just for the
video
taping which like i said that's pretty
decent money for 87 and then like
another 9 000 for finishing out the
movie
so of course she needs the money she
seems a little weirded out but not that
weirded out and you know what i mean
because it's like a lot of money she
needs it so she's kind of like okay well
i have to go upstate new york for a few
days her boyfriend husband whoever is
kind of like pissed off about it because
he's like well you know where are you
going to be but she leaves a number it
seems all very on the up and up
so roddy mcdowell's character
his name is mr murray
he drives her upstate new york and uh
like in this raging snowstorm so they go
like i said up to this really remote
mansion
at which point she meets this guy named
dr lewis whose house this presumably is
now he is a paraplegic and i guess he's
a retired psychiatrist
and you find out later that mr murray
writing mcdowell's character used to be
a patient of his so again that's like a
little bit that was you find that out a
little bit later on uh obviously dr
lewis was kind of like a big hunter type
person because there's like all these
big like stuffed polar bears and [ __ ]
like that there's also like chekhov's
bear trap up in the attic so you know
you'll you know that'll come into play
later on
um initially like i said so they
explained to her the situation that this
you know poor actress you know she took
off and they really need somebody that
looks exactly like her so and she was
like wow you really do look exactly like
her um but they do have to like cut her
hair because her hair is very like big
80s curly
at the beginning and i guess julie rose
the actress had kind of like a short
straight bob so they're like so they cut
her hair they dye it like more in line
with the color they give her pictures
and show her like parts of you know or
show her what she looks like so you can
kind of like uh you know make yourself
look like that um you know but that's
kind of the story they give so they set
up this
this video thing they're like so they
have the video camera you can tell that
obviously this is probably not a movie
type situation because they're a little
even though they have like all the you
know the white umbrellas and the lights
and everything and it looks sort of
professional but the way they're going
about stuff is not super professional
like the guy doesn't really say action
um you know roddy mcdowell's kind of
like tripping over the light thing so
it's kind of like a little bit of a
ramshackle kind of thing but she
apparently does okay on the screen test
so they make this video tape it you know
just to see what she looks like on
camera like to make sure she looks
enough like the other actress supposedly
um like i said you know from the jump
that this is not really what's going on
because this is a thriller so you know
it's going to be some nefarious like
some diabolical kind of [ __ ] going on so
so yeah but she and she is i mean to her
credit she is kind of like initially
suspicious just kind of like this just
seems really weird it's like nobody else
is here like other than you two guys
like at this big isolated house
and they're basically like yeah we're
just making this videotape and then
we're gonna take it to the producer's
house or you know or whatever and uh you
know and we'll see how it goes from
there
so she's like okay whatever and like i
said initially both the guys seem super
nice and super welcoming it's you know
bratty mcdowell like brings her some
more milk like before she goes to bed
and everything like that it's like he's
nice but he's like overly overly nice a
little bit so you're just kind of like
getting a little bit creeped out ronnie
mcdowell is good in this by the way uh
because he's like super friendly but
also like really sinister like even from
the beginning so uh yeah so as it goes
on like little things she's like oh i
told my husband that as soon as i got
here i would call him and they're like
oh of course of course you can there's a
phone in the kitchen so she goes in
there and like tries to make a phone
call but then there's no dial tone and
then you know they have an excuse for
that though they're just like oh there's
a really bad storm out it's like a
blizzard which there was and the lines
go down sometimes but you know it's all
good if the lines aren't back up
tomorrow you know i'll have mr murray
like drive you into town and you can use
a phone there you know don't worry about
it so like i said even though there's
like little things like that that are
kind of like oh this is kind of weird
nothing that's too too alarming
however very shortly into her stay
a couple things happen
one thing is that the videotape that she
makes ronnie mcdowell who he's gonna
like take her to use a phone the next
day but of course the car won't start
because he's like oh you know this
engine must be frozen up or anything
like that so like i said there is a
blizzard outside so that does sound
totally legitimate but uh so they're
like oh well
darn we can't take you to town to use
the phone to like call your husband so
you can tell them that you got here
safely so there's that situation but
then later on we see roddy mcdowell
going back out and like fiddling around
like underneath the hood of the car and
then getting back in the car works just
fine so obviously he did that [ __ ] on
purpose
now he takes the videotape to this other
house
where this woman who you can't really
see is like peeking out one of the
upstairs windows and he just like
basically slips the videotape like into
the mail slot
and then they show the woman from the
back like you can't see her she's
watching the videotape later and the
first part of it is mary steenburgen
doing her
doing the scene supposedly as this julie
rose actress woman and interestingly the
the scene that she talks about is very
much like kind of the prologue that we
saw at the beginning of the movie with
the woman getting killed in the car and
her finger cut off and all that
now after you see her part then like the
like the doctor guy comes on and he says
something like well here you go here's
the proof that she's still alive like i
said you know that there's some kind of
weird like blackmail kidnapping
something like that going on and
obviously this isn't a movie obviously
mary steenbergen
or katie got hired
quote unquote hired or brought there
abducted
what she was didn't know it was abducted
uh got brought there because she looked
like somebody
that these two guys whatever their
scheme is are trying to like make
somebody else think that she's still
alive even though clearly she's probably
not like i said and that's not really a
spoiler because obviously you know that
that's going on from from that videotape
it makes it pretty obvious
so then like i said katie doesn't really
she's a little bit suspicious but not
super suspicious but then
um there's one scene where they're kind
of like all hanging out of the parlor or
whatever like having tea
and she's kind of standing by the
fireplace and she looks in the fireplace
and she sees what appears to be
like a part of her driver's license
which
alarming
so she kind of like pretends she didn't
see anything but then she races up to
her room like the guest room opens her
wallet and all of her [ __ ] is gone like
all of her like her driver's license all
her credit cards everything a little bit
upsetting now
at this point she kind of feels like
well
i don't know if she's like gonna
confront because she does actually
confront the old guy like later on but
in a way too she kind of seems like well
maybe it's better to like keep this [ __ ]
on the dl
because you don't know like what they're
capable of and like i said it's kind of
snowing out she does actually try to
escape from the house but it's freezing
cold outside obviously and she only has
like a little bit of a shawl or
something on over her clothes so she
doesn't get very far and obviously like
ronnie mcdowell like chases her and
finds her and brings her back to the
house but just like in apparently the
original movie they're trying to
convince her that she's just like
imagining all this stuff oh you didn't
see your driver's license that's silly
why would we do that and uh she's like
yeah but all my [ __ ] has gone on in my
wallet oh you probably just forgot it
all you know how you ladies are it's
like you know what i mean y'all don't
know how to do anything you don't know
how
sight works you don't know you know what
i mean so that's kind of like where the
gaslighting thing comes in and honestly
because uh the doctor like the
paraplegic guy because he was a
psychiatrist at some point he's able to
convince like if she starts flipping out
like because at one point she does
actually find like a working phone in
the house and is able to call the cops
but one thing she doesn't know exactly
where she's at because you know they
drove like a couple of hours into
upstate new york she wasn't she like she
fell asleep on the road she wasn't super
paying attention um so she does not
really unwisely is i'm not victim
blaming i'm just saying unwisely doesn't
really know the name of the town or
doesn't even know the address of the
house or anything like that um you know
and this was back before they could
really trace that kind of stuff like
unless you're on the phone for a really
long time
so because like nowadays it's like an
idiot but back then you had to be on the
phone for like x minutes or whatever
before they could trace the location or
at least they could trace the location
where the phone call was coming from so
yeah so at this point what they do it's
like they basically drug her
and lock her in her room now while she's
drugged
she's she's freaking out at this point
and like the two guys are totally trying
to like gaslight it's like we seriously
you're just imagining all this we would
never hurt you we're not trying to do
anything bad um you know everything
you've seen thus far has just been your
imagination
um you know the only thing we didn't
tell you because they do actually tell
them later on oh julie rose uh you know
the actress she was supposed to be
replacing um didn't actually just have a
nervous breakdown she also like
committed suicide and they had to tell
her that because she was poking around
in one of the rooms and found
inexplicably some polaroids of what
appeared to be julie rose's corpse it
looks like it's a corpse but it looks
like her
i don't know why you'd take pictures of
that well like i said i guess it's like
this elaborate blackmail scheme so they
were like look she's dead but you know
polaroid that big i don't know that'd be
really easy to fake but like i said
there's a lot of plot holes in this just
don't worry about it too much so they
lock her in a room or no they say we're
not gonna hurt you we're not gonna
bother you you can lock the room if you
want if you're really that worried about
it so like i said very gas lady so she
not only like locks the door of her
bedroom she also like piles all the
[ __ ] furniture in front of it what
she doesn't know though is that there is
actually like a secret entrance to her
room like behind the full-length mirror
and apparently like while she's drugged
uh roddy mcdowell comes in there and
cuts off her finger which you'll note is
the same finger that was cut off the
woman at the beginning of the movie
so
basically so like i said she caught she
is able to call the cops the cops come
but then you know uh the doctor is able
to convince her she's my patient she's
delusional uh she does this kind of
stuff all the time so like everything
she's like there's a body upstairs
because she finds like the other corpse
um you know of julie rose like in the
attic or whatever and she's like trying
to tell them it's like they're trying to
kill me they cut my finger off they did
this out and the other thing but uh of
course you know after the doctor and
ronnie mcdowell convinced them that
she's a crazy person they're just kind
of like yeah that's cool then they go up
to the attic and they can't find the
body
uh because they're not looking that hard
to be fair
not super helpful these cops but uh but
yeah so um but like i said she does
actually end up finding a phone at some
point and she not only calls cops but
she also calls her husband
and even though she's not entirely sure
where she's at and she sounds a little
bit incoherent because she's freaking
out and like they just cut her finger
off which you know that would be a
little alarming for anybody so she's not
really able to come up with any really
good details for them to be able to find
her like she's just like the town is
called pine something you know what i
mean she's like i can't remember and
then all she can remember is like go she
says something about goldfish because
when they stopped at a gas station like
on the way up to the house for they
again inexplicably uh over ten dollars
worth of gas and they give you two free
goldfish they just give them to you to
back like in the middle of winter i just
kind of like i don't know why but uh
yeah so it was goldfish
but so she did remember that so her uh
her husband and brother um actually do
kind of like figure out just by and she
remembers something about a cupboard
bridge and so just by triangulating how
long she was probably on the road where
the covered bridges were and stuff like
that they are actually able to kind of
try to track her down but it's taking
like a really long time for them to get
up there and meanwhile uh the two guys
you know the doctor and roddy mcdowell
have you know take taken away all
pretense that they're actually have her
best interests at heart and uh are just
straight up trying to like get rid of
her now so like i said i don't know if i
want to spoil the
necessarily the resolution of the
mystery but like i said the really my
complaint about this is that the
resolution is that the mystery is so
complicated that i wasn't really sure
like i had to re like i watched the
movie and i'm just kind of like wait
what and then you know what i mean and
then i was like i think i kind of get it
but then like i read the wikipedia page
and i'm just like
uh i don't know i still like i get it
but i don't really know
i i guess like the motivations weren't
like crystal crystal clear to me it's
you know what i mean it had to do with
you know yes she was trying to she was
basically hired to replace
this woman that was dead but was
supposed to be alive which i got that
but the weird thing is that
she's dead but then her sister was the
one that killed her
but then they wanted to convince her
sister that she was still alive even
though i don't know it was like this
whole thing but well you know i guess i
get it i don't know well like i said i
don't want to get too much into it
because it's a thriller and you kind of
want to figure the mystery out as as it
goes i'm not i think what the thing is
i'm not like confused about the sister
murdering and stuff like that but i am
confused about why
the doctor the psychiatrist who
apparently the sister whose name was
evelyn and is also played by mary
steenberg and so mary steenburgen
actually plays like three parts in this
why the psychiatrist convinced evelyn
to blackmail her sister to begin with
like i think that was what was confusing
me i'm like what would be the motivation
of that
like she's your patient and
the sisters hated each other so he's
like oh i have an idea why don't you
just blackmail your sister and she's
like oh good idea but then she ends up
killing her instead i don't know it's
like it's like i said it's super
convoluted and i don't really know how
how different it is from the original
film like i said this is a very very
loose
remake because in the original movie as
far as i could determine uh you know the
woman's one it's in england uh this is
set in canada although it's supposed to
be upstate new york but they shot it in
and around toronto the original one's in
england and it was a young woman who was
not an actress but she was just going
for a job like she was gonna go be a
live-in secretary for an old woman and
then gets
they kind of like try to make her
somebody else you know what i mean like
they they say that she has like a
nervous breakdown and you're this other
person so i guess that's kind of what
happens in this they're but they're not
trying to convince her that she's julie
rose
necessarily um they're trying to pass
her off as julie rose to someone else
and then later on when she starts to
twig onto the fact that something
nefarious is going on then they're
trying to like convince other people
that she's actually this person that's
dead just so they don't get in trouble
you know what i mean so i guess it's
like it's similar but it's not exactly
the same like i said if you're into like
80s
thrillers
ones like death trap or something like
that and you haven't seen this one
because i feel like i didn't realize how
[ __ ]
forgotten and obscure this was because i
don't know why it's like for some reason
something about this one maybe it was
like the wintertime setting or like i
said the actors that were in it who i
was liked and i watched a lot of their
movies in the 80s but it's like i
remember seeing this so many times on
cable back in the 80s and it obviously
you know struck a chord or you know i
remembered a lot about it where i
remembered like the title of it and i
remember liking it because as soon as i
saw it like come up on amazon prime a
couple weeks ago i was like oh yeah i
remember that like with that creepy old
house and
you know and all that so i so i was like
excited because i was like i remember
watching that a bunch of times on cable
and it's not like i had i'd forgotten
like i said what the plot was but i kind
of remembered like how the house was
cool and it was all wintery and
everything but that was kind of all i
remembered so it was really interesting
to
revisit it i don't i don't think i liked
it as much this time just because
like i said some of the plot holes are
kind of like glaring but it's honestly
it's you know like i said you could say
that about a lot of thrillers um you
know they're not
i mean the whole the whole genre is
supposed to be these
these ridiculously complex plots that
would never work in real life i mean you
know what i mean that's kind of like
what the whole genre of the movies are
of those movies are so i mean if you can
get past that if this is actually like a
really lot of fun uh i think ronnie
mcdowell is my favorite thing about it
because he's just
playing such a good he's sort of like
the friendly villain type of thing uh
the doctor guy is kind of like he's kind
of sinister too but he doesn't come
across as sinister as roddy mcdowell
does even though ronnie mcdowell is kind
of like this
there he's like overly friendly
type of thing but it's like in a way
that's sort of like creepy so i think
he's a lot more
intimidating and scary than the guy in
the wheelchair is even though i think
the guy in the wheelchair is supposed to
be because because rodney mcdowell's
character is basically just his
manservant i'm not really sure like he
just kind of lives there and he just
does all his stuff for him like he
cooks for him and like takes care of the
house and you know does all the casting
he did the casting call thing so he's
his driver so he just that's kind of
like his
his servant or his valet or whatever i
guess he is but uh but yeah so he but he
comes across as more sinister even
though he's friendlier initially if that
makes any sense but yeah so it's on
amazon prime like i said it was free for
a little while which is why i kind of
got excited about re-watching it but
then
when i went to watch it yesterday they
didn't have the free one available
anymore so you had to pay 3.99 but like
i said you know if you like thrillers
from the 80s and you haven't seen this
one and you want to see one that's kind
of like a little bit forgotten about uh
then it's totally worth the four dollars
uh if you want to check it out if
anybody else has seen this because i
feel like nobody's seen it but me if any
of y'all have seen this uh tell me what
you thought about it in the comments and
uh you know we'll talk about it we'll
see what uh what you thought of the
mystery and everything like that and
that will do it for this flickers of
fear i will see you guys on the next one
bye